he is the first undisputed WWF Champion
of all time 32 total wrestling titles
six-time WWE Champion and the host of
talk is Jericho podcast on podcast 1
which is where you can check out this
podcast every single day on the Rich
Eisen show know as a four-letter word is
his new book that's the sound of the
book hitting the desk it is next of
which Chris Jericho is sitting good to
see you I want to say that you have the
best logo thank you I love this like the
fugitive like Band on the Run type thing
it's like madman is little Reservoir
Dogs like you're on the run like this
mean anything you're on the run from the
cops or on the run from an angry husband
or whatever it may be but I really like
what I'm on the run from is neither of
what you just mentioned I'm running to
something which is the 40-yard dash line
at the Scouting Combine every year in my
suit and ties I've done every single oh
so there's a thing behind it there is a
thing behind it and it's a great use of
the word thing because it is not fast
this is the thing it is something yes
you could be running towards the
bookstore to buy a copy of no Simmons
segue was that speaking up sweet you got
Paul Stanley to do the floor were do the
Ford so here's the story behind this
book so I've done three autobiographies
in like eight years and I like to write
and I got a lot of ridiculous stories
and I thought do we really need a fourth
Chris Jericho autobiography made a
little bit overkill I'm not like Jack
Kerouac or something like that ice so I
always get asked like how did you get
into wrestling how did you get into
music how did you make make it in both
yes so I decided to put together like 20
lessons 20 principles that I had learned
from famous people fictional characters
friends of mine that enabled me to
attain these goals hmm so one of the
principles is the gene Simmons principle
which is always dressed like a star
always look like a star the Paul Stanley
principle is eliminate negativity okay
the Oder principle is do not do not try
do no there's no try there's only do so
every little thing like all these little
lessons and putting together so now I'm
like a motivational speaker not rich
look at you I'm like the next like Tony
Robbins Robbins little yeah I'm the next
Tony Little and Tony Robbins is what I'm
saying right now okay I like it and what
is
and Paul Stanley's all your speed oh
well here's the thing so there is this
quote that I saw when I was 16 years old
from a documentary that Paul was in they
said the only people that are gonna tell
you you can't do something are the ones
that have failed I'm not gonna tell you
that you can't do something cuz I did it
you can do it and to me was like you
stalking me you can do it because I
wanted to be a wrestler and I wanted to
be in a rock and roll band and look at
you so here we are full circle I now
friends with Paul asked me to do the
forward to the book so his quote is what
started this and now he's doesn't afford
for my books well I had which is awesome
great way for you to to go full circle
like that I remember the number of times
in the summer or the fall of 1994 when I
was driving around upstate New York with
my tapes trying to bust into the
television business I've seriously and
then ever sending the tapes around the
country looking for a job a number of
times I was told no right and I took
that as an insult I really did
especially one spot in upstate New York
I went and I found the operation because
it hadn't been started yet it was like a
24/7 365 news cable operation that was
being started out in the Troy
Schenectady Albany area okay buddy at
home spell Schenectady if you're not
from there impossible don't even do it
sober
even so and so reason why I'm telling
you this is I hadn't started up yet and
I got a letter saying we received your
tape and this is before GPS on your
phone I I drove to the address I stopped
at a gas station asked for directions
and I found the people in their house
hmm and the guy looked at me in the face
and standing in his living room he told
me I don't have any time for any of this
drop the S bomb and said I don't have
time for walking mm-hmm and sent me on
my way and I went back in my car in the
middle of Schenectady and I'm like what
the hell am I gonna do next and I
thought to myself exactly pretty much
what you saying on your book cover that
no is a four-letter word
well people I found like it really is an
ugly word because the people throw that
word out very easily and accept it very
easily I always like to dis construct
the know and find out how can I build it
into a yes because I think it's a lot of
laziness involved and people think that
people
give up very easily with a nil you can
look at you now beautiful set great
great guest and where's that guy in
Schenectady now nowhere shoveling snow
for five bucks an hour I define to have
a silhouette of him on you know
silhouettes on his mug but no is each
also I mean do you have do you have kids
yeah three kids okay but knows an
important word to teach kids though well
she's growing up this is not here no
this is not no like if you ask didn't
know was a four-letter word if you ask a
girl on a date and she says no or you
know you want an extra cookie I'm
talking about success and building your
career and living your life with an
attitude of like I'm going to do this if
you believe in it and believe in
yourself right that's the Jericho
principle believe in yourself because no
one else will okay you don't have to
accept it you can do it you could do
anything you want to do and that sounds
like real philosophical type of like I
have the the the rules that prove that
and in this book well what's the Vince
McMahon rule oh wow
it's called work hard and then work
harder is the hardest worker in the room
is that right it's true I guess you know
rich if you wanted once again you have
to put in the work you have to put in
the time the sacrifice you know and all
of those principles make sense
chris jericho here on the rich johnson
show um would you ever want to go back
to work for Vince McMahon oh absolutely
I've got a great relationship I stopped
working there in May I think last year
2016 might have been the best run of my
career but I always come and go it's
it's it's the right way to do things at
this stage because if you're around too
long you know you almost get taken for
granted it's like you know you're the
old old prostitute on the street of
those Jericho you know he's always good
but I just compare myself to an old
prostitute you're not gonna hear that
anywhere else but you know that would I
leave there always wanting more and then
come back and then leave and come back
sure but I love working for Vince he's
great and he's such a unique character I
love writing about him because I have so
many great stories and interesting
stories and weird stories and he'll
never write a book because he doesn't
like talking about himself it does like
writing about himself so if he doesn't
want to do it I will
hmm so it's it's a interesting
relationship that we have well it's
amazing again Chris Jericho here in the
Rich Eisen show what wrestler
have made of themselves outside of right
okay John Cena is like I mean he's
turning himself into a bona fide yeah
he's on the brand economic actor leading
man you know but like I said if you look
through the guys okay so you got you
know obviously the rock doing and you
got Cena excuse me president rock well
actually I have no doubt that that's
gonna happen a seriously not supposed to
be sir do you think he's gonna I do I
think not to get political but I think
we're in the era now of a celebrity
presidents I think our current president
got in because he knew how to work a
camera I think rock knows how to work a
camera better than Trump does and has
much more charisma and much more likable
so you know if that is if you look that
you don't even need experience to be a
president anymore all you need to do is
just like have the celebrity value so I
honestly think the rock will run for
president okay I really did so then walk
me through all the other ones that
you're about to well so then the Cena
legitimate you know about to be leading
others Dave Bautista who has made I
think three billion dollars in he's a
guardian of the galaxy and he's now he's
gonna be in Blade Runner and he's gonna
do a movie with Jodie Foster but then
you know he could throw Jericho in now I
got for New York Times bestselling books
I got a number one song on the radio I
got a one of the biggest podcasts in the
world you see dat alongside yours this
is all stemming from the work ethic of
Vince McMahon and also too there's no
prima donnas allowed in the devil to be
there's no you know this coffee's too
cold throwing it against the wall and
storming out
you do your job you do the work you're
supposed to do you don't act like a
prima donna and you stay until until the
job is done so when we come out into the
other other world you know show business
Hollywood wherever maybe people are
always surprised about the work ethic
and how easy we are to get along with
because that's the way we're taught you
do not act like a dick with Vince and
his people well Twain Johnson's work
ethic has become legendary here sure
absolutely for real yeah absolutely if
he's always got something going on this
project this project and you're always
thinking bigger you know seems like a
good friend that's what you need to do
like even with with with with my podcast
it was doing really good so then I was
falling Corollas model he has the Adam
Carolla Network he's coming in tomorrow
I'm gonna his show tomorrow ace man
we'll meet each other in the wake of
that but now I have a podcast network
the Jericho network where I find shows
bring them on and kind of cultivate that
way you have to think big like why
should I just have a podcast why
shouldn't have a whole network why not
give it a try no one's gonna tell me no
Chris Jericho here on the rich Johnson
show what he got for me on Ric Flair
what do you know about him yeah I mean
like that we were just talking earlier
like he was from what I understand was
close to the edge like sounded like this
20% chance of surviving this thing and
then you know two days ago he posts a
video on on Instagram wearing a shirt
this is a mutt dead yet mother effort so
you got a thing about this so the guy
was in a plane crash broke his back but
survived got hit by lightning
who gets struck by lightning he did he's
the Keith Richards of wrestling as far
as the amount of you know substances and
everything and he almost dies from this
whatever complications he had but he's
still this guy is like like I said I'm
like Nature Boy Ric Flair will not die
he's not supposed to die right and
that's why it doesn't surprise me that
he's back and you'll probably he'll
probably be sitting on this couch in
three months you know driving you crazy
I heard a story that he had he had know
he had lost his memory like when he came
out of this he was foggy he wasn't
thinking he was using a walker and they
were giving a physiotherapy and just out
of nowhere he put the Walker down and
started strutting and saying whew just
out of instinct like that's how you kind
of knew he's feeling belgae he's wooing
is that a true story what I heard or is
that like some sort of Chuck Norris tale
or does it really matter struck by
lightning so we'll say history what was
it again yeah you grew up around the New
York Rangers right yeah my dad was a
ranger from 70 to 75 so like glory years
of the Rangers right know this earlier
you do guys this is a ROG you bear a
Jackman Vic Hadfield Emile Francis the
cat was the general manager of the team
that was the year of that my dad played
so my dad was on I kept me with it was
like the big check-in light is him Pete
stemkowski and Bruce burger
and they you know they they fought
everybody they were the check in line
but my dad scored 22 goals a year two
years three years he did 18 22 and 29 so
that's like a modern day now we call
them power forwards back then they were
just tough sons of [ __ ] and the guy
could put the puck in the net sure if he
was around now he'd be making what 8
million a year 10 million whatever it
may be is a power forward like that but
that's like I said when you go to New
York and you know this you're from New
York people still ask me all the time
hey I stayed here if it number 27 as
your father wherever you go you go to
the garden there's still guys that work
there that we're working there in the
70s my dad played do you have any
memories there because you were like 4
or 5 I was 40 I was 3 or 4 and I
remember a couple things one I remember
hating going to the garden because it
was so loud like there's so loud
screaming I used to put like this little
sweater that I had over my head and then
the other one member is like one time
I'd added a breakaway and I was waving
at him he never waved back and I was so
pissed off like why aren't you waving at
me so it's cool though because my actual
25th anniversary of wrestling to the day
October 2nd 2015 was in the garden we
had a show in the garden so I was like
from the panocha mousse Hall and in
pinoke Alberta the Madison Square Garden
continuing the lineage of you know the
Irvin family in the garden it was pretty
pretty cool
let pretty damn cool everything about
you man no is a four-letter word how I
failed spelling but succeeded in life
yeah by Chris Jericho there you go right
here into it go check it out
bookstores near you and online stores
garbage cans photographs way they'll be
on sale for a dollar pretty soon we can
be the orange sticker on look at you
there's even pictures in there guys you
are yeah look at ya we got you at you're
the baby-faced assassin I like it that's
my dad he was called the baby-faced
assassin right yeah and that's another
one they weren't gonna see this a
self-help book is called they weren't
gonna put pictures in it I was like
putting pictures in it and I was such a
pain in the ass they put pictures like
16 pages of pictures and then I was
still mad that they weren't in color
look everybody Jericho just stop while
your head and get out of our office so
there's fine pictures I want them to be
in color
they're in black and white which is just
as good it's all good it's fun Congrats
one book Congrats on this Congrats on
this that's rich please come back any
time
absolutely okay the next time can we put
me on the other side of this running
dude what more do you need you've got a
podcast your music and wrestling you're
in books what more do you need I want a
man just have a mug I want your logo as
well I'm gonna take over loads a game of
Thrones I'm gonna attack new Khaleesi
he just Recaros my mug by the way did
you like that well that's what she said
stroke arse for the dragon I just used
it as a verb you did is opposed to he
made you entirely jakar was a great
Cologne when I was a kid let me tell you
something yeah when I was in high school
because we were right around the same
I'm 48 you're about to be 47 okay
Drakkar Noir meant business oh yeah in
high school absolutely excuse me only to
be outdone by a gentleman named Paco
Rabanne I never went to Paco I was would
like to do cries well I saved up my
money to buy a thing in her car cuz I
thought that means business oh it didn't
work but it smell good and now the the
the uber driver just like douses himself
oh yeah that was like really cheap
cologne you know there's a mold spice
remember that one you like you just on
there yeah put your hand you dabbed it
on yeah yeah my dad my dad had canoe Wow
yes I don't know that one oh yeah you
remember the hole was the one who knew
polo was won by La Fleur what was the
last Cologne you put on I don't wear
Cologne Wow should I wear Cologne you
should that's why you sitting over there
by yourself if you had cologne everyone
be sitting by you that's a good point
being friends with you did your own
company did your car noir work for you
del Teufel yes many names in the DJ
booth this has been a good show G Clark
Clark Joyce Tamar Paul Stanley to run an
old [ __ ] on the street and in the rock
what more do you want on the bike I
think we need to quit well we should
pressing you should have quit five
minutes
this has been my favorite part of a
great conversation that I've been doing
from start to finish
check out Chris Jericho's new book no is
a four-letter word on podcast one check
out his podcast talk as Jericho of
course he's the lead vocalist of Fozzie
I'm I can't even there's not enough time
left the Antonio Browns calling and okay
so I can't read all of your credits he's
not gonna talk about your car noir
I am Jericho we asked Antonio Brown what
his Colonus yes should this is making
the theme of the day his cologne is
touchdown oh yes by fabergé eight four
four two oh four when we come back
pharmaceutical or practice squatter
that's next year in the Rich Eisen Jimmy
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you liked that
video be sure to download our app don't
have any memory on your phone let's
start to delete some of those slow-mo
videos you have and you know which ones
I'm talking about